la dame aux états unis malgré le succès
de la marche qu'ils ont organisé
récemment de selma à montgomery et la
prise de conscience du problème racial
qu'elle a suscitée dans l'opinion
publique américaine
les militants intégrationniste noir
savent maintenant qu'ils devront lutter
pour suivre avec obstination leur
campagne de revendications non violente
avant que l'égalité si vite qu'ils
exigent ne soit une réalité effective de
leur vie quotidienne et l'on verra sans
doute encore longtemps dans les états du
sud des scènes comme celle ci qui s'est
déroulée récemment dans l'alabama à
camden où la police locale a dispersé à
la grenade lacrymogène une manifestation
non violente en faveur de l'égalité
raciale
à
mais les champs les prières et les
marches symboliques des noirs n'ont pas
ému du tout le grand sorcier impériale
du ku klux klan robert shelton et les
quelques dizaines de milliers d'adeptes
de cette secte fanatique qui sont
fermement décidés à maintenir l'ordre
ancien et considère désormais le
président johnson comme leur ennemi
numéro un
depuis que ce dernier a stigmatisé avec
vigueur les activités de cette société
secrète de la haine raciale